this week I want to write about time
travel movies so I'm bring on a very
special guest from the future Andre from
the YouTube channel black nerd comedy
Andre thanks so much for traveling back
in time to join me know it takes
1.21 jigowatts again I didn't travel
back in time I traveled here from
Southern California I'm wearing this to
protect me from the smog in LA and gang
warfare
well Southern California that's a
different time zone so that's still
format I know it is still California so
we're the same time zone
kind of work with me here man all right
fine
I'm from the future beep boop boop up
first your comp Miko Wildcat Road what's
your opinion about terminator genisys
the idea it's introducing the series
well it's trying to be prequel and a
sequel and a reboot it should just try
not to suck like the last one and
there's multiple time travel scenarios
but kind of confused x-men days of
future past and all that going against
it still pulled it off maybe this can I
think I would rather play Terminator on
Sega Genesis than see Terminator Genisys
on day two things got me thinking about
time travel this week one is a new Hot
Tub Time Machine sequels about to come
out the other we are now living in the
year 2015 which of course of course
yeah you're Marty McFly traveled
forwards to this second back to the
future
we're in the future I don't know about
you but I wish I was living in the 2015
of that movie hoverboard yes holographic
movies yes 77 was a dream Pepsi perfect
Pepsi the perfect way better than
Crystal Pepsi and Nike they leave
themselves led tie-dyed ball caps I
promise it won't look stupid I look like
a reject Fresh Prince of bel-air you
know there are a few things you're
always gonna see when you're gonna
there's robots everywhere people in the
movies in the future they're slaves to
their technology you sure yeah I knew
that was me
oh really oh that's good I'm liking that
oh okay well are we talking about time
travel Hot Tub Time Machine 2 and Back
to the Future 2 are both about people
trying to use time travel to get rich
and that screws everything up and then
someone asks is zip around fixing stuff
but I'm not gonna worry about going back
in time the other thing about time
travel is unless you're a white guy you
don't want to go back in time woman or
you don't want to do it Trey come on
hungry let's go back to 18 third oh uh
oh yeah whoo
all right I'm good if Rufus pops up in a
phone booth and says we're gonna show
you the history I'm like nah I'm good
I saw Selma I'm all right and then what
kills me too is no matter what part of
the world you are in if you're in the
80s everyone talks like a valley girl or
a surfer dude sorry in the 80s we don't
all fell like ninja turtles okay we're
not only turtle space
now that would be written it's
absolutely everyone we had the name of
all different artists yeah this is
Jackson Pollock in return he's got like
a big rock we've said our piece now we
want to hear from you what is your
favorite time travel movie let us know
in the comments and be sure to subscribe
to the wired Channel and while you're in
a subscribing mood make sure you go over
to my channel black nerd comedy and
subscribe there too and more importantly
if you click right here
what is face imma put it on your face if
you click that you can see us together
on my channel talking about everything
that's wrong with turning animated
movies into live-action movies
Andre thanks again for joining me you'll
be pleased to know that you can keep
this pimping great you're so kind
and now let's pantomime like we're
having a serious discussion you're
really gonna make me take this at home
oh yeah it's attached to my body I want
to talk smart yeah yeah okay I can see
why they don't actually